hello there I'm Gavin der and welcome to
this lovely 4k slo-mo video we're gonna
be injecting ink into water and filming
it's pretty Ness hope you'll get some
nice silky we've got a few different
colors and a full tank of water sorry
we're going to film this on the Phantom
flex 4k we've got some lovely white
backgrounds that Dan taped to a tree and
a tank of water so we got some different
different variants of ink we are some
pearlescent ones sort of metallic
looking little bits of glitter looks
like this one looks cute isn't it cool
that it's watery but look how it seems
like the thinker one is look better in
the water because they kind of blend
less yeah they takes longer for them to
mix in with the rest of the water so
sort of keep their shape it's cool I
think this turquoise ones gonna look
really good alright what colors this
Daniel yeah try some yellow ink yep
alright you know what you're doing it
yeah yeah okay it's good really yep oh
nice
delectable that is that's gorgeous in it
cool that is glory look at that uh I'd
like to do that again a silken home okay
look at the light play on the air light
play the lights playing on the on the
surface of the Internet are you almost
Aron there be that's what it is
air rising up pulling the ink with it Oh
so now we embark on the very lengthy
process of refilling the tank oh this is
the longest setup for this shot but due
for many other shots to us this is
probably longer so it's always annoying
when the the actual action is you know
point five of a second and the reset at
fifteen minutes why I'd rather do is do
all of these as separate elements at the
same exposure and then I can just
overlay them on each other Oh coming in
from my different angles in there yeah
yeah
so 12
oh okay so I'm gonna get about half a
tablespoon of this ink half a tablet one
half a tablespoon ish look at lovely
whoa that's some good ink look lovely
look at that that's just a Lux and a
beautiful look how silky guys
come from wanna probably blast that way
and where your finger is now so I'd be
like yeah and fire
wicked oh look at that I look really
good that's cool
that's awesome that's really good I
approve
hey well well done us I think that was
one of the best-looking videos we've
ever made
yeah that's one of my favorites so cool
watching all the silky clouds gonna like
the pool yeah some of the colors didn't
really work so well like the Reds didn't
look little boy was by far the favorite
one yeah that was awesome thanks for
watching that video be sure to follow us
on Twitter get a t-shirt get t-shirt in
that and subscribe we make slow-mo all
the time don't we yeah oh open egg white
ice oh thank you my eye yeah good in
your hair and your Oman almost full let
it know your bloody neck you're such a
bouncy service I can't right back at me
no that's that diffing turquoise in it
they baby baby baby blue Twitter bird
blue so it is Twitter bird birth cute
isn't it as much as me doing the Twitter
noise oh good pressure that's too much
American I guess it's like this is good